all right there are plans for a
bipartisan congressional committee to
investigate the deadly assault on the
capitol but they are in disarray this
morning
house speaker nancy pelosi rejected two
of republican leader kevin mccarthy's
five picks for the panel
both of those congressmen have opposed
an investigation into what happened on
january 6.
chris van cleave has more from capitol
hill chris good morning
good morning speaker pelosi justified
her decision saying
january 6 is so important it warranted
this
unprecedented action kevin mccarthy then
blasted her for playing politics
and said the gop will do its own
investigation let's be clear here both
parties are going to claim victory
because this plays directly to their
bases
pelosi has broken this institution the
top republican in the house kevin
mccarthy slammed the stunning surprise
from speaker nancy pelosi
rejecting two republican fire brands for
the january 6th select committee
the speaker denied congressman jim
jordan and jim banks
citing the integrity of the
investigation and pointing to previous
statements made by the two
it's always been about getting the
president no matter what
jordan and banks are both outspoken
allies of former president trump
whose supporters made up the mob that
stormed the capitol
both also voted to overturn the election
and previously criticized the committee
they just want to be partisan they just
want to continue to attack the former
president
they want to play their political games
pelosi's move drew an immediate response
from mccarthy
why are you allowing a lame duck
speaker to destroy this institution
this is the people's house not pelosi's
house
he announced he'd pull all five of his
appointed members and instead
republicans would do their own
investigation if the speaker
doesn't reverse course pelosi fired back
for somebody breaking with her party liz
cheney is the lone republican staying on
the january 6 committee
she said she supports the speaker's
decision and criticized mccarthy
and at every opportunity the minority
leader
has attempted to prevent the american
people from understanding what happened
to block this investigation
cheney is still on this panel because
she was appointed by the speaker not
kevin mccarthy the select committee's
first hearing is set for tuesday they
will be hearing from law enforcement
officers
who were at the capitol on january 6.
anthony
chris thank you